one of the reasons that I don't go home
for the holidays is that a lot of people
haven't grown since I left they haven't
had 10 years of growth they've lived the
same six months 20 times and when I go
back they want to meet me in my past and
so they want to speak things over me
that aren't Who I Am anymore and then
because it's difficult for them to
connect their perception of who I used
to be and who the person is sitting in
front of them reconciling those two
things is really difficult for a lot of
people because it's breaking the Box
they want to put you in but the reality
is that most people don't change
entrepreneurs do because we have to we
call it growth instead of change